في الضفه الغربيه افاد مراسل الجزيره
باقتحام قوات اسرائيليه خاصه مخيم الفارعه
جنوب طوباس بالتزامن مع تحليق مكثف
للطائرات الاستطلاعيه الاسرائيليه واشار
مراسلنا الى ان اشتباكات اندلعت بين
مقاومين وقوات الاحتلال دارت في المخيم
كما دفعت قوات الاحتلال بتعزيزات عسكريه
اضافيه عبر حاجز الحمراء من جانبه توجهت
من جانبها توجهت طواقم الاسع التابعه
للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني الى مخيم الفارعه
تحسبا لوقوع
اصابات من مدخل مخيم الفارعه جنوب طوباس
ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره ليث جعار لنبدا
معك ليث باخر التطورات والمعلومات عن مخيم
الفارعه واقتحام قوات الاحتلال لهذا
المخيم
نعم بالفعل عمليه عسكريه جديده لمخيم
الفارعه جنوب محافظه طوباس في هذه اللحظات
حيث وصلت وحدات خاصه اسرائيليه حاصرت احد
الاحياء في داخل المخيم من ثم بدات
التعزيزات العسكريه الاسرائيليه تصل تباعا
الى محيط المخيم حيث بدا بالفعل محاصره
المخيم من عده انحاء تحديدا من المدخل
الرئيسي حيث تت واجد عشرات الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه برفقه جرافات وصلت
من حاجز الحمرا الى الشرق من المحافظه حيث
بدات بالفعل هنا بدا تواجد للتعزيزات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه وهنا ايضا على
الطريق الاخر هناك تواجد عسكري اسرائيلي
وتعزيزات جديده تصل اتباعا بين الفينه
والاخرى نحو المخيم حيث حتى هذه اللحظه لا
ت زال تدور اشتباكات مسلحه ما بين
المقاومين وقوات الاحتلال ال التي تحاصر
المخيم من كافه الارجاء في هذه اللحظات
عمليه تعزيزات عسكريه وتقدم لبعض الاليات
العسكريه في هذه الاثناء بدا واضحا امام
تحديدا امام المدخل الرئيسي الذي يظهر في
هذه الصوره حيث بدا بالفعل ارجاع المركبات
الفلسطينيه منعها من التقدم و لتزامن مع
ذلك بدات الاليات العسكريه تدخل الى داخل
مخيم الفارعه وسط الاشتباكات التي لا تزال
متواصله حتى هذه اللحظه
والانفجارات المتتاليه قبل لحظات فقط كان
هناك استهداف واضح واشتباكات مسلحه من قبل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه باتجاه اليات
الاحتلال والوحدات الخاصه التي اقتحمت
داخل هذا المخيم بالتزامن مع هذه العمليه
العسكريه تواصل للطائرات الاستطلاع التي
لا تزال تجوب سماء مخيم الفارعه حتى هذه
اللحظه وبعض هذه الطائرات
المسيره تحلق على امتداد يعني منخفض جدا
في محيط المخيم هذا لربما يعني في محاوله
للاحتلال باستهداف او محاوله لاستهداف بعض
المقاومين او بعض المواطنين عبر الطائرات
المسيره بعض هذه الطائرات هي طائرات مفخخه
ايه يعني يتم استهداف بها ال اي جسم متحرك
وبات الاحتلال يستخدمها خلال الاقتحامات
المتواصله هنا مركبات الاسعاف تحاول وتصل
تباعا نحو هذا المخيم في محاوله ل يعني
الوصول للاصابات التي وقعت داخل هذا
المخيم وبناء على هذا الاشتباك الاصابات
هناك اصابه على الاقل حتى هذه اللحظه في
المخيم على واقع الاشتباكات المتواصله في
محيط هذا او في داخل تحديدا هذا المخيم
هنا عند سوق المخيم او الطريق والساحه
الرئيسيه في المخيم المواجهات والاشتباكات
لا تزال متواصله قوات الاحتلال تدفع
بالتعزيز العسكريه الاسرائيليه المتواصله
نحو هذا المخيم بالتزامن مع ذلك هناك يعني
ايه خروج لبعض الاليات العسكريه وخروج ال
لاليات عسكريه اسرائيليه جديده من حاجز
الحمراء الى الشمال او الجنوب الشرقي عفوا
من المخيم باتجاه هذه المنطقه بالفعل وصلت
بعض التعزيزات العسكريه والاشتباكات لا
تزال متواصله تحديدا في وسط المخيم
والساحه الرئيسيه ايضا في جنوب المخيم
تحديدا الشارع الالتفافي عند جنوب المخيم
هناك اشتباكات مسلحه ومواجهات لا تزال
تدور حتى هذه اللحظه من مدخل مخي الفارعه
جنوب طوباس مراسل الجزيره ليف جعار شكرا
جزيلا لك